There's no way I can do it if I order it as a prince. This is a sacred lineage.
Is
n't it
the place where you feel the best
? You won't realize if you do
n't say the coordination. In the future, you'll move the country.
It was so much fun
me
Let's talk seriously
I can't talk
Angelica-san
Red Grave If you turn your mind to the enemy, your
position will be shaken and
you will be deprived of the right to succeed to the throne If you understand, do
you really choose that?
I can't get into Angelica's place soon.
It's okay if me Marie is there.
[Music]
Luke Sion
analysis is finished by It
's possible to ensure the safety of later people. It's
difficult to adjust the day.
Impact
[Music]
[Applause  ]
User
World Boli-do